I never thought of myself as being
interested in fashion but a while ago I
gave a talk at the women's magazine
called Harper's Bazaar and I met all
kinds of people actually it was
fantastic I gave a talk in front of the
best dressed women I ever seen it was
kind of interesting and I talked about
my my research and after that we kept on
talking about all kinds of topics among
them was the issue of fake so so think
about this I imagine these these glasses
either by designer called Cloe and what
would happen if they were fake oh if
they were real when you go in New York
and the places to buy fake stuff
everywhere what is the impact on that
and the interest the reason I thought
this was interesting is that when you
were something that is fake you yourself
know it's fake but for the rest of the
world the quality of fake is really
quite good this happens to be a real one
but the quality of fake is usually quite
good and it's hard to tell the
difference so what what would happen if
you are wearing something fake now we've
done lots of research on cheating we've
shown all kinds of things about cheating
when people cheat Monmouth when people
cheat less but one of the things that
was curious was how does one act of
cheating creates a tendency for another
act of cheating in for another act of
cheating so we used sunglasses and fake
and we got Chloe to give us sunglasses
some looked like these some look
different we had lots of them
what do you think so
imagine you come to the experiment and
you feel a computer survey about all
kinds of choices about fake versus real
and at the end of the survey we say to
you you know what based on your answer
you kind of the person that chooses fake
stuff often so please take these fake
glasses put them on go outside is a list
of posters hanging on evaluate the color
the texture how does it look like we use
these fake glasses people do this for
five minutes and then they came back and
we gave them tasks that tempted them to
cheat these tasks were basically a
square
with diagonal and there was some dots
some on the right of the diagonal some
on the left of the nagging oh and we
asked people what were the more dots on
the right or on the left very simple but
what happened was that we paid people 10
times more if they said right think
about in the following way imagine you
were a physician and you had a patient
and there was treatment a and treatment
B and treatment a was the better one for
the patient not the right answer but
treatment B gave you more money as the
physician what would you choose and the
nice thing about these tasks is people
could do it couple of hundreds of times
and basically what we saw is it over
time people she did a little bit and
then at some point they started cheating
more like was kind of transitional
period the question is when will this
transition happen and how much do people
cheat and what we saw was that the
people with the fake glasses cheated
quite a lot and started cheating quite
early in the process but of course we
had a control condition in which we did
the same thing people answer the same
server we said now you kind of the
person who buy real glasses here are
some real glasses for you please wear
them take them around and they went
through the same task those people
cheated much less and by the way we
repeated the task a few more times in
one one time they didn't do the survey
we just said you take the fake you take
the real and the results were identical
people don't have to think it's their
own choice it's enough that they are
worrying something that is fake to make
this and finally we asked how does
wearing something fake changes your
perception about other people around you
your friends how much are you suspecting
them that when they say oh honey I have
to work late in the office or if you say
excuses like this people are really
lying and it turns out that once people
were fake they think it's much more
likely that other people are lying as
well so here's what happened you were
something fake nobody else know but you
know and because you know your moral
standard is kind of a little grinded
it's kind of a little lower and now it's
easier to take the next step into
cheating and the next step into cheating
in the next step in the cheating and it
also shades your perception of other
people you think everybody around you is
a little cheat as well so up to now when
we were thinking about cheating we
thought about the fashion industry we
thought about oh you know who is losing
from it are they charging too much
there's a question of morality of what's
really legal
it's illegal what is the fashion
industry losing but I think there's
something deeper in it and the deeper
thing is that the moment we cheat the
moment we think of herself as cheater
and especially with fashion because it's
something that stays with us something
we wear we think about so imagine this
was fake sunglasses every time I would
wear them I would think to myself oh my
goodness I'm wearing these fake
sunglasses and I might be proud to
myself saying oh I got this really good
deal but at the same time recognizing
that they're fake might reduce my
honesty just a little bit and get me
just a little bit more likely to do
other acts of dishonesty and that I
think is a very sad fact